I treat these things like paintings I
don't know how to color black I don't
care about traditional way of design I
just see it and I do it I feel it hello
everybody this is Dr baklava Action
Bronson this is my life in sneakers
[Music]
when I was a child I was the only child
so all my cousins spoiled me my mom
everybody spoiled me rotten I added more
I literally had every shoe that was
coming out in a kid's size for every
name that you could imagine every sports
athlete that had a piece of Footwear I
had it
Barry Sanders Dion Sanders hideo Nomo
Shacks lots of shacks not just V1 V2 V3
shagnosis Frank Thomas big hurts I don't
know which one I covered it the most I
think it might have been a Griffey I'd
really love the Griffey or Barkley with
the humongous teeth on the side the
cb-34s said Sir Charles on the bottom
back then when I was a youth there was a
store on Austin Street in Forest Hills
called kings and queens my eyes were
seeing Air Max 95 when they came out all
the different tuned Macs and all the
crazy stuff as it was coming out these
humongous air bubbles appearing on shoes
and crazy colors and going
ridiculously past the upper Shin with a
basketball shoe I love that stuff the
crazy Runners that were coming at the
time I always went on to an obscure shoe
as I got older there was more places
that we went to and Broadway near 6th
Avenue going towards Manhattan Mall it
was a store with the Chinese man in
there that had everything wrapped up in
plastic preserved Air Raids Reebok Pump
aerobic ones the purple magenta pump the
ones that no one had eatonics
original Asics split up the middle in
Crazy colors this is when all those
stores downtown were opening up as well
like clientele and Norm de gear and
crazy sneakers and collabs started
happening East Bay that magazine was
more important than newspaper
with me that was more important to the
Time Magazine I remember ordering the
Cheryl swoops back then I would wear
from size 8 to an 11 depending on sock
thickness whatever you know if you find
something hot you gotta get it it was a
different kind of character as you could
tell
man it's like heavy just hurt me in the
stomach New Balance 992 has to be on
there probably around 97.98 my mother
introduced me to the New Balance shoe
she was wearing them for foot Comfort we
had friends in the neighborhood and that
would
speak to us and tell us about the olden
days and one of them referencing why
they would wear the New Balance shoe and
the reflectors because when you take
pictures you would be the one that would
be shining that always struck a chord
with me I love reflection I love 3M I
love that company they make all kinds of
amazing things like Scotch tape I can't
give you what I like what my favorite
shoes are because it's been so many
years of shoes there's been so many
names
throughout the years all the off-brand
ones I love all the Air Maxes that you
can't even remember that name
I love those
so let's go with all that
let's go with the 90s
period
let's go when new shoes would come out
and there were new designs there were
fire now everything is just regurgitated
colors mean everything colors mean
numbers colors mean movement colors mean
everything when you say a color do you
see things I do I see all kinds of
things I smell things I like adding
bonus features
this whole lining right here is 3M as
well copper 3M it's like rising out of
the swamps we got a nice tidal wave on
on the sole this is a piece of baklava
to me and it's also a crocodile rising
out of the water it's just Beauty and
design it's just in my mind this is the
canvas and this is the palette this is
it this right here this mesh this neon
mesh somehow I love the color I love
neon blast on top of a dull rust it
brings life to the situation that seems
so done this also reminds me of the
Ninja Turtles you know reminds me of
ooze
[Music]
man I have 100 drawings on my iPad on my
phone just the way that I do pretty much
anything is just overwhelms me so I did
a bunch of different color ways and they
send you the cads and everything like
that I don't know how to do any of those
type of thing so I have a friend of mine
who is a partner in crime Aaron KR one
of the illest design dudes that there is
around very well versed in the sneaker
world so he knows what materials can be
used where and this and that we didn't
have a long time so I'm not gonna lie I
had to nail it on the first try
so we nailed it on the first try
they're on my feet I wanted to modernize
a classic Navy
and hit him with every different type of
blue that you possibly can Aqua slate on
the trim and then when you see on the
inside you get the aquamarine on the in
there dark Navy you got the ice on the
bottom a little bit of sky in the back
just that hint of purple
that ties into blue for me I'm calling
these lapis lazuli one of my favorite
Stones the thinking man Stone
none they come as is I don't want you
changing my to painting you don't
go up to a painting and put
another stroke on it I don't know what
they did with this new 990 V6 no
because I'd be saying this even
if I wasn't involved whatever materials
they use they gave you bounce that that
shoe has and the stability of the
Heritage 990 so
I feel like
I have the power when I'm running and
walking
and if I loosen them up chill but I wear
different shoes for different things so
if I'm doing something specifically
where I'm like squatting heavy or doing
things where I'm leg
situations you want something flat or
you go barefoot if I'm running around on
the track or on the treadmill I'm
putting on the hokas I'm putting on
these
I debuted my own shoe author Ash stadium
and flushing Queens in
front of twenty thousand I've done a lot
of crazy and it's hard to
articulate sometimes what I've done and
like I don't really like to talk about
it but this was crazy I've been
watching wrestling for my entire life I
got the call that the legend from ECW
tez I hear that they're doing some sort
of Big Show in Queens at Arthur Ash
Stadium Grand Slam situation Taz lets me
know listen man we want to do an angle
so I start training
[Music]
10 weeks of training being in the ring
it all culminated to me performing a
song that me and Harry Fraud made in
2014 Arthur Ashe Stadium 20 000 people
sold out screaming and
then after I did the song I got in the
ring and I wrestled I did moves you know
I did a running power slam I
showed athleticism and it was all
because of the grip that I had from the
shoe
I'm training you see all these medieval
utensils around so I'm always ready if
you stay ready you don't have to get
ready thank you everybody for checking
in on this episode of my life and
sneakers
it's your boy sincerely Flushing Queens
my shoe the 990 V6 baklava comes out in
March keep your eyes out for it make
sure I appreciate everybody I love you
love yourself
foreign
[Music]